بكل فخر
واعتزاز امام حاله الصمود الاسطوري التي
يسطرها الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه شعب صامد مرابط قابض على الجمر جمر
الالم والجوع
والحرمان يتحمل المجازر والجرائم التي
ترتكب بحقه كل يوم على
بشاعتها وقبحها
ونزها
ونبعث برساله
مباركه
لاهلنا في
المقاومه لرجال
القسام ورجال سرايا القدس وكل ابطال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع العزه
والاباء
والصمود الذين يواصلون تمريغ انف ضباط
وجنود الاحتلال واساءه
وجههم ويواصلون تدفيع قادتهم ثمن احتلالهم
لارضنا وثمن جرائم بحق شعبنا وارضنا
ومقدساتنا والاعتزاز
كذلك بكل المقاومات التي تسند غزه وتدافع
عنها وعن
شعبها ساتحدث اليوم في اربعه عناوين في
الوضع الانساني والميداني وما يتعلق
بجرائم
الاحتلال وفي جوله بلنك الخامسه للمنطقه
منذ بدا العدوان وفي المواقف الدوليه وفي
جلسه محكمه
العدل فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني
والميداني وجرائم الاحتلال
النازي فكما اشرت قبل قليل لليوم
ال6 يواصل الاحتلال الصهيوني عدوانه
النازيه وحرب الاباده
الجماعيه والتي يشنها بكل وحشيه واجرام
وساديه ضد اكثر من مليوني فلسطيني من
ابناء شعبنا في قطاع غزه مستخدما فيها كل
انواع الاسلحه والقنابل المحرمه دوليا
والمرسله اليه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مستهدفا فيها النساء والاطفال
وكبار السن والمرضى والمدنيين والابرياء
ولم تقتصر هذه الجرائم النازيه على قطاع
غزه فح
فهي ممتده ومتواصله في عموم الضفه وفي
مدينه القدس عبر حصار المدن والمخيمات
وجرائم الاغتيال المتعمد بدم بارد
والاعتقال والتدمير الممنهج للبيوت
والبنيه التحتيه فقد بلغ عدد الشهداء في
الضفه ضفه العياش حتى الان اكثر من
350 شهيدا منذ الس من اكتوبر اي منذ بدايه
معركه طوفان
الاقصى وشهد
العالم يوم امس كيف قامت اليات جيش
الاحتلال عمدا
وانتقاما بدهس احد الشهداء في مدينه
طولكرم بعد ان قتلته رصاصات جنود الاحتلال
النازي وبكل دم بارد وفي جنين استهدفت
مسيره صهيونيه مجموعه من
الشبان تقي منهم سبعه من الشهداء اربعه
منهم
اشقاء لم يدع هذا الاحتلال النازي جريمه
الا
وارتكب في انتهاك صارخ لكل الشرائع
والاعراف والمواثيق والقانون الدولي
الانساني من قتل جماعي وتهجير قصري
واعتقال للمدنيين الابرياء
وتعذيبهم وتعريتهم وتصويرهم وهم عراه
واستهداف ممنهج للاطفال قتلا ومؤخرا
خطفا واستهداف للنساء وقنص لهن وهن يخرجن
من اماكن الايواء
باوامر وتدمير لكل مقومات الحياه
الانسانيه في قطاع غزه من مستشفيات ومراكز
ايواء تابعه للاونروا ومن مدارس وجامعات
ومساجد وكنائس والمراكز الخدميه و وصل
اجرامه حد نبش المقابر وتجريف وتدنيس
جثامين الشهداء وسرقه
اعضائها ايضا مع ارتفاع اعداد النازحين
وعدم توفر اماكن للايواء تصلح للحياه ومع
قله وشح المساعدات التي تصل الى مناطق
قطاع غزه المختلف فان اهلنا في قطاع غزه
يواجهون خطر الموت كل يوم والوضع الانساني
بمعنى الكلمه كارثي في قطاع غزه وهو
بكارثه ينذر بارتفاع اعداد الشهداء
والجرحى والمرضى والنازحين ضمن النازحين
بشكل كبير فمن لم يمت بالقصف والحرق
والقنص مات بالجوع والعطش والمرض وكلها
باتت اسلحه صهيونيه امريكيه تستخدم ضد
الشعب
الفلسطيني اننا ننتظر مع تعيين السيده
سيجرت كاخ التي باشرت امس الاثنين مهمتها
التي اسندها اليها الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو جوتيريش ككبير منسقي
الشؤون الانسانيه واعاده الاعمار في غزه
ننتظر منها تحركا عاجلا وعملا جادا ينهي
معاناه المدنيين الفلسطينيين في كل مناطق
قطاع غزه وننتظر من منها ان تتجاوز كل
ضغوط الاحتلال واملاء ته وكل محاولات
الاداره الامريكيه لتعطيل المهام
الانسانيه في قطاع غزه ان المطلوب منها ان
تسعى وبشكل عاجل لتدفق وصول المساعدات
الكافيه الى جميع مناطق قطاع غزه خاصه
مناطق الشمال التي وصلت حد المجاعه
الفعليه وان تسعى لادخال الوقود الى
المستشفيات والمخابز ومحطات ضخ المياه
ومحطات الصرف الصحي وان تعمل على تشغيل
مرافق العمل المدني التي دمرها الاحتلال
وهذه مسؤوليه عاجله واويه ملحه امامها
وعلى كل الدول والحكومات والمؤسسات
الامميه
المعنيه ان تسعى لدعمها وصولا الى وقف
العدوان الهمجي النازي على شعبنا في قطاع
غزه
اننا هنا وفي الوضع الميداني نؤكد انه على
مدار اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر كامله لم يحقق
هذا العدو النازي ايا من اهدافه العدوانيه
التي اطلقها منذ ان بدا
عدوانه وهو يحاول عبر تصعيد الجرائم
الوحشيه ضد الابرياء والمدنيين من الاطفال
والنساء احراز صوره نصر مزعوم مع انسحابات
من قطاع غزه لا سما منطقه الشمال لكنه لن
يحرز هذه الصوره ولن تتحقق له بفضل الله
اولا ثم بصمود شعبنا وبساله المقاومه التي
صمدت حتى غادر الاحتلال مناطق شمال غزه
ومدينه
غزه ان تسويق الاحتلال النازي بالشراكه مع
الاداره الامريكيه لما يسمى الانتقال
للمرحله الثالثه من الحرب ياتي في سياق
دعايه سوداء كاذبه ومكشوفه عند شعبنا
ومقاومتنا وهي محاوله يائسه لتمريرها
كانجا على حساب دماء شعبنا في ظل استمرار
كل اشكال المجازر والجرائم في قطاع غزه
ونحن نؤكد اذ نتحدث عن فشل العدو في تحقيق
اي من اهدافه ان اسرى العدو الصهيوني لدى
المقاومه لن يعودوا اح الى عائلاتهم ما لم
يستجب نتنياهو واركان عدوانه في حكومه
حربه الفاشله لشروط المقاومه واولها الوقف
الشامل والكامل للعدوان على قطاع
غزه فيما يتعلق بجوله بلينكن وهي الزياره
الخامسه للمنطقه منذ بدا
العدوان مع كل جوله من جولاته
الخمس في منطقتنا ياتي بلينكن ليبيع وهما
لكل الدول التي يلتقي بها
وقادتها اذ ينظر بعين واحده لما يجري في
المنطقه عين تتبنى روايه
الاحتلال وتدعم اجندته في تصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه واباده شعبنا
الفلسطيني ولا تزال الاداره الامريكيه عبر
مسؤوليها تواصل تبني روايه الاحتلال
المضلله ودعايته الكاذبه
في محاولاتها لتبرير الاباده الجماعيه
التي يرتكبها جيش الاحتلال النازي ضد
المدنيين ولا تزال تردد ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تتمركز بين المدنيين في سياسه
مكشوفه لغسل يدي الاحتلال من دماء الاطفال
والنساء والشيوخ والمدنيين في غزه لقد
تجاوز عدد الشهداء 30 الف بين شهيد
ومفقود وكثير من المفقودين تحت الركام ولا
تزال الاداره الامريكيه لا تنظر الى الامر
الا بالعين الاسرائيليه ان هذا يعكس مدى
التورط الامريكي في هذه الجرائم وتورط
الاداره الامريكيه تحديدا في الانتهاكات
الواسعه لكافه القوانين الدوليه التي
يرتكبها جيش الاحتلال الاحتلال النازي في
قطاع
غزه اما حول حديث بلينكن بان العديد من
دول المنطقه ابدت استعدادا للاست مار في
مستقبل غزه فاننا نجدد التاكيد ان الشعب
الفلسطيني هو سيد قراره وهو المعني بتقرير
مصيره وحده دون تدخل من
احد وان تقرير مصيره لن يكون الا وفق
رؤيته الوطنيه المتمثله بالحريه والتحرير
والانعتاق من الاحتلال واقامه دولته
المستقله كامله السياده على ارض وطنه
وعاصمتها القدس في الوقت ذاته فاننا نؤكد
على موقف شعبنا المرحب باي جهد عربي
واسلامي مساند لقضيه شعبنا وداعم للمقاومه
ومؤيد لانهاء العدوان وازاله الاحتلال
واثار هذا العدوان النازي على شعبنا
وارضنا
ومقدساتنا الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه اننا ندعو الاداره الامريكيه
مجددا الى التوقف عن سياستها التي تعطل
جهود انهاء حرب الاباده التي يشنها
الاحتلال في غزه وان تعمل فورا على وقف
هذا العدوان الاجرامي وان تكف عن العبث
بالقوانين والانظمه الدوليه لصالح
الاحتلال النازي وعدوانه على
غزه ثالثا فيما يتعلق بالمواقف الدوليه من
العدوان حول الجلسه العامه للامم المتحده
للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده التي عقدت
يوم امس الثلاثاء بخصوص نا قشه استخدام
الفيتو من قبل الولايات المتحده في مجلس
الامن في جلسته المنعقده في الثاني من
كانون اول ديسمبر عام
2023 الماضي الذي كان لتعطيل قرار يطالب
بوقف فوري للعدوان الصهيوني على قطاع غزه
فاننا نؤكد ما يلي ان الاداره الامريكيه
لا تزال تواصل ممارسه كل اشكال الدعم لهذا
العدوان الصهيوني من اجل راره واطاله امده
وهي تفعل ذلك خدمه للاحتلال ومن واقع
شراكه كامله في جرائمه وعدوانه مما يحملها
المسؤوليه السياسيه
والقانونيه والاخلاقيه
والانسانيه عن معاناه والام وقتل وتشريد
اكثر من مليوني مواطن فلسطيني في قطاع غزه
بالحديث عن المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه استطيع
اقول انها مسؤوليه
مزعومه اذ ثبت انه لا قيم ولا اخلاق لدى
هذه
الاداره ان افشال الاداره الامريكيه لصدور
قرارات من مجلس الامن الدولي بوقف العدوان
وتحدي اراده ومواقف
13 دوله في الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
طالب طالبت بوقف هذا العدوان يجعل هذه
الاداره منبوذه وراعيه للارهاب الصهيوني
فمواقف ودعمها للاحتلال وجرائمه سيزيد من
عزلتها وخسارتها سياسيا ودبلوماسيا
وشعبيا وسيح طم صورتها الاخلاقيه المزعومه
ويؤكد كذلك علاقتها
ورعايتها لكل اشكال الارهاب في العالم
وليس الارهاب الصهيونيه
وحسب اخيرا فيما يخص جلسه محكمه العدل
الدوليه غدا
الخميس فاننا نرحب ونثمن مواقف كل الدول
التي ايدت موقف جمهوريه جنوب افريقيا
التاريخي الشجاع والمشرف كذلك في رفع هذه
الدعوه ضد الاحتلال النازي وندعو محكمه
العدل الدوليه الى عدم الرضوخ للضغوط
والاملاء التي تسعى بها الاداره الامريكيه
لتعطيل عمل هذه المحكمه اذ ان هذه الاداره
تعد شريكه وتتحمل المسؤوليه عن استمرار
حرب الاباده الجماعيه التي لا تزال ترتكب
ضد شعبنا في
غزه ان المواقف التي عبر عنها الوزير
بلينكن من هذه الدعوه القضائيه التي
رفعتها دوله جنوب افريقيا في محكمه العدل
الدوليه ضد الاحتلال ومنها قوله ان هذه
الخطوه تشتت جهود احتواء التصعيد وان دعوه
الاباده الجماعيه امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه بلا اساس هي محاوله امريكيه
للتعمير على الحقيقه حقيقه الجرائم التي
يرتكبها الاحتلال في غزه وهي محاوله
لتعطيل ادوات العداله الدوليه عن القيام
بدورها بعد تعطيل ادوات السياسه الدوليه
في اطار دعم الاداره الامريكيه الكامله
لجريمه الاباده الجماعيه التي يرتكبها
الاحتلال ضد المدنيين في قطاع غزه وهي
كذلك تعكس قلقا جديا لدى الاداره
الامريكيه باعتبارها شريكه في هذه جريمه
وان اي قرار يصدر عن المحكمه سيطال هذه
الاداره ان عاجلا ام اجلا وفي هذا
السياق سؤال لابد للاداره الامريكيه ان
تجيب عنه هل قتل الاحتلال ل 300 من
المدنيين معظمهم من النساء والاطفال لا
يمثل اساسا لقضيه اباده جماعيه وهل سياسه
التجويع والتعطيش وقطع مصادر المياه لسكان
غزه لا ت يمثل اساسا في الاباده الجماعيه
وهل تدمير 70% من بنيه قطاع غزه لا تمثل
جريمه اباده
جماعيه ام ان تدمير 30 مشفى وقتل الاطباء
والصحفيين لا يعد اساسا لقضيه اباده
جماعيه ان مثل هذا الحديث الذي يصدر عن
الاداره الامريكيه انما هو تعبير واضح عن
النفاق والكذب وسياسه الكيل بمكيالين
لاداره بايدن المتورطه فعلا في هذه
الاباده
ختاما الرحمه والمجد والخلود لشهداء شعبنا
وامتنا في كل الساحات على طريق تحرير
القدس
وفلسطين والشفاء العاجل للجرحى والمرضى
والحريه للاسرى والمعتقلين والنصر باذن
الله والعزه لشعبنا
ومقاومتنا ولكل المقاومه في منطقتنا وانه
لجهاد نصر او استشهاد والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
وبركاته